Um, airplane jacks.
Airplane jacks.
Set an alarm, set a 20 minute timer.
Do you like the, um, like, aerospace stuff too, or?
I mean, yeah, we wouldn't want to, like, shoot rockets and stuff.
Right?
Okay, well cleaned out.
So, um, I guess before...
I get started.
I can give you a little...
Have you been in the lab yet?
Have you seen this place yet?
Yes, I've been here once before.
And I've gotten like a quick tour.
I know this machine is what turns the solid metal into metal powder.
And there's some other stations where people are working on the AI to monitor it.
Yep, that's right.
Me and Ronnie are the only ones that are allowed to operate this machine just because there's some sensitive parts that can get damaged easily.
But there's a lot that goes into surrounding what we do with it that we just don't have time for.
So we'll need your help with that.
We'll play a real critical role with that.
Dr.
Bird loves it when we record everything.
So he has this funny collar that I have to wear.
I hope we get some, like, metaglasses or something, because that would be way better than, like, this, you know?
Yeah.
But for now, I feel like a cow.
So, you, I think, are you in the lab through that, like, program?
Yeah, the higher class?
Mm-hmm.
Yes, I am.
And that's, like, it's, like, five hours a week, I think, is what you promised you'll do or whatever.
I don't know.
I don't remember.
We have, like, those classes once a week.
But I don't know if there was, like, a limit for how many hours we're working on it.
I know it's, like, a credit class.
Uh-huh.
Oh, it's a class?
Yeah.
That's cool.
So how much time do you think you can dedicate to this every week then?
Usually, Tuesdays and Thursdays are when I'm most free.
Monday, Wednesday, and Friday are extremely busy.
Mondays and Fridays are extremely busy?
Yeah, and Wednesdays.
And Wednesdays?
So Tuesdays and Thursdays are going to be your more open days?
Those are the golden hours.
So me and Ronnie put together this list of things we need help with.
and i'll try to order them for you um like top priority first i should
have done this before but i'll kind of go over them with you real quick so oh my
oh my it loves me have you
worked with excel at all with what excel like spreadsheets yes i know what they are i mostly use like google sheets and stuff
In the aluminum tubes?
Yeah.
You're saying in like the little cups we...
When I was talking with Dr.
Barrett, he said that there's like a aluminum shell you guys have that you fill with metal.
And then that gets put into the crew school, melted down, and then turned into powder.
Yeah, so we're just at the start of this.
So we're still kind of putting together...
like, experiments with this.
So right now, the two powders we're really working with are ALSI10MG, which is like aluminum and silicon and magnesium, right?
And then just pure aluminum powder.
So I can show you.
What is that?
That might be for my most recent run.
So this is just a little bit here.
So this is aluminum?
Yeah, that's all aluminum powder.
There's some more of it.
So you see it needs to be...
What's it called sifted still get some chunks in it.
Yeah, I see it Yeah, it's pretty awesome.
So that's what we're that's what we're making right now is mostly aluminum family stuff, but like we're like Scandium and erbium or copper Magnet more magnesium There's
like less than 16 elements that we're gonna be Kind of put it in the other and see what we can get out with it.
Yeah IPA
is
uh oh my gosh was it alcohol alcohol i spoke alcohol okay so we use this like thing on everything um
when we're handling any like the atomizer which i guess you won't be but like any anything that has powders on it we just don't want to like get on our skin yeah so make sure we're close especially something like uh
mercury or something yeah it'd be really bad okay so i just sent you on this list um
So let me go over with you some of these things so that it ranks generally in priority.
So one of the first things we need, we need some things or like some tools and some clip, one of these clips.
So if you want to take a picture of that and just find one, you can take a measurement of the...
Do you like any markings showing measurements or what type of T-screw it is?
Let's see.
I don't...
There's a number six on it.
Six.
You can probably take a picture of the tube markings, too, to help you know for size.
Yeah, probably.
It looks like six millimeter diameter for the tube.
But, mm-hmm.
So we need one of those.
And then we need some tools.
Here, I can see the tool list.
You can just find them on Amazon, probably, honestly.
But do you know how to put together ME orders?
I don't.
Here, I'll send you the link for it.
So when we buy stuff in the lab, we have to put it through here.
It's pretty easy.
All right, I'm going to sign in.
Just sign in.
We're just like the startup.
We're just scrappy and hungry and getting it done, you know?
All right, so coming to new orders.
No, that's not it.
New order.
Okay, so account code.
I'm going to get on my laptop.
I can show you a little bit easier.
Have you done any research before this lab?
Nope, this is my first one.
Cool.
So this is that link I sent you.
So you'll go to new order.
It'll look like this.
And you say order this from me.
Constance should not be hazardous.
So this is what I need to text you.
Maybe, you know, maybe it would be better is all screen record.
This is going to send it to you so you have a demonstration.
Okay, so new order.
Order this from me.
Then the account code, CC10111.
And then the same thing for the department code.
Faculty account.
If you type in like Sterling, it should pull up his name.
Select that option.
Merchant name.
Okay, so in here, this is where you'll put like, you know, Amazon.
You put description of the item.
A link to the like exact item that you're purchasing.
Gotcha.
And then you can add several things.
Just fill out all this stuff as best you can.
Not everything has to be filled out, but everything you can, you know?
Okay.
Got it.
And then project name.
So this, you can just put, like, for atomizer workflow purpose.
It's the purpose of the thing.
And then physical location, CB150.
And then your email at the bottom.
Got it.
And that'll send, like, confirmation emails and such?
Yep.
So that'll send, that'll send, um, when you,
when you put those together send the the link to um dr baird and also me and ronnie so we welcome them and then before before you submit like the um
before you submit the purchase order just check with me and ronnie make sure that we're we're good with what what you're buying all right does
that all make sense yeah um only thing i'm wondering is uh what kind of tools do you guys still need
Yeah, I've got that list for you.
I don't know.
I forgot what these are called.
Okay, so
here's the list I just sent it to you on Slack.
Let me know if you have any questions about those.
I'll show you the brushes we need.
So this is what we have right now.
And we're cleaning out the whole inside of this container, like every surface.
Oh, everything?
Everything, yeah, with these.
And so we need like...
some bigger brushes for for pushing powder around inside um so okay is it like metal brushes these are these are just plastic yeah so
where do you like sweep it to do you sweep it all out of the machine we put it down into the machine because
it's all it's all product that we can keep so okay yeah does this like tip over that's loose yeah it's just sitting there yeah so like you you
won't be cleaning the machine but like
We just, yeah, if you can find some good brushes for that, just let us know what you find.
Do you have any questions about the other things on the list I sent you?
I don't have like a specific preference.
We just need something that's probably like stainless steel and like a card.
So something like...
So like a steel sponge or something that you can...
Not a sponge, something like a scraper.
Like literally like a card like this, but stainless steel.
Yeah.
So you can just see what you find at that and let us know.
And then what's the tape measure for?
Just a general purpose tape measure.
Okay.
Yeah.
And then the other things in that list, like before the things we ordered.
Do you have any questions about that stuff?
Let's see.
Order needed tools.
Build an Excel sheet.
Enter in info for each powder run.
Create a system to organize powders and stubs physically.
Organizing my bathroom.
We can talk more about that later.
Okay, what's the SEM stubs?
So SEM stubs, let's see.
I don't know if he has something.
Let's go out.
Let me get a jar of powder.
So every single one of these powders we need to characterize under an electron microscope.
And so the powder needs to be applied to stubs like this one.
And that's what you put it under to scan it?
Mm-hmm.
So...
I don't know if we should have some more.
Okay, so these are all stubs we've made.
So this black stuff is carbon tape.
So what you literally just do, what we'll have you do is take one of these, make sure you're wearing gloves because they've been cleaned with isopropyl alcohol.
Okay.
And then attach the carbon tape sticker.
And then literally you'll just open this very carefully.
You might even want to wear a mask for it.
And with your glove finger or with like tweezers or something.
You just dip it in?
Uh-huh.
And then this carbon tape is sticky, so it'll pick up some of the powder just like that.
Gotcha.
And then you scan the powder.
Yep.
So, like, there doesn't need to be a lot.
Like, see, there's on these ones just enough to cover the surface well.
And then, you know, shake off any excess.
All right.
So that's pretty easy.
So these, I'll show you back on the thing again.
So every single run.
we've got all these parameters that we need and put it into an excel sheet okay cfc plate what's cfc
stand for cfc is a carbon fiber um it's one of these guys okay i can't remember what c on the end is though i wrote this um
so yeah this is the plate type the
amplitude that we used for atomizing them, the melt temperature, the type of aluminum.